it's time for The Adventures of [ __ ]
man and his trusty sidekick post for
[ __ ] wonder all statistics phony
stories and outright lie
no bullsh is too big for [ __ ] man
and his trusty sidekick bullsh
[Music]
oh I know I installed it
hello commissioner [ __ ] yes sir
right away sir understood sir looks like
the Second Amendment is under attack
again and the book darkness under both
minions in the mainstream media are on
full cylinders the Siemens a lot going
on here
that's the tricky thing about ng second
time in both bitless boy is that it can
rear its ugly Bo's dead too soon it's
coming our way
Sybil's boy it's the outside of books
statistic bit more firearm ownership
least a greater violent crime despite
the fact the FBI statistics show that
the murder rate as of 2013 is decreased
from five point six to four point four
four hundred thousand oh no it's the
bullet that most shootings are committed
with fully semi-automatic rifles despite
the fact that the FBI shows most are
committed with word of the mail handguns
get that Bush oh no if the post isn't
that gun free zones keep us safe despite
the fact that Bush was a punk in 2009
ever since the 92% of mass shootings
have been committed loophole there is no
gun show loophole boy we're gonna save a
lot of federal books exempting pictures
or online transactions from any other
firearm transaction not a single one
but whoops
we'll come back the shirts Bill O'Reilly
will grow past interns the anti Second
Amended push always comes back we raked
out one possible get right now there's
always one other big pile of us looking
to take his place of just radical great
day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes sir commissioner both bit we can say
with complete confidence that this post
is officially solved yes Mel treats and
won the Golden Glove
Thurston Post cover reinforcements yes
sir for the continued Adventures of
[ __ ] man
tune in next time same bow tie same
[ __ ] channel you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button it's a
circular button now that says subscribe
if not head on over the Young Turks
that's probably more your speed although
they're coming over at [ __ ] we know
you're here watching I can smell you
from here there's also a recommended
video box playing right up there you can
join the monk little otter with
credit.com slash mug Club for daily
content so we're not dependent here on
YouTube shank no go you don't need to
stay here this isn't good for it's bad
for your soul